على سبيل المثال، إدخال الطعام، على سبيل المثال، إدخال الماء
على سبيل المثال، لا يمكن إدخال الوقود إلى سكان غزة
أنني سأقاتل زيت ومن ناحية أخرى سأدعمهم وأعطيهم
وتزويدهم بالوقود والغذاء قدر استطاعتي
لإخضاع العدو إذا سمحت له بمساحة للعيش
فكيف أقهر عدوا إذا أمدته
لديه كل ما يحتاجه للحصول على السلطة
الكفاح من أجل الحصول على الطاقة الشمسية للقتال
هذا أمر لا يمكن تصوره، لذا سأقف ضده
لأنني لست مستعدًا لقبول أن هناك انخفاضًا
في قصف مدفعي من الجو جنوب قطاع غزة
لماذا، لأننا رحمنا، اغفر لي من أجل الزيتون
أنهم لا يقومون بالإخلاء إذا كنت في منطقة قتال
إشعار الإخلاء لسكان غزة وزيم لن يتم إخلاؤهم، فهم أبنائي
الموت وليست هناك حاجة لمناورة برية واسعة النطاق إذا قمت بذلك
يمكن أن تقصف من الجو ومع كل الاحترام الواجب في ثلاثة
في الأسابيع القليلة الماضية ترى انخفاضًا في الشدة
من القصف الجوي حينها
للوقوف ل